sinclair la question c'est celle du
contrat de mariage c'est que ça la
question
et à chaque fois dans le contrat de
mariage c'est pour notre pomme le 40
longues sorties d'alstom sont partis
chez les américains je veux dire c'est
qu'on a tout perdu on est on est reparti
en slip et nous avait il nous avait
promis un 50 50
au final on a été dépouillé de notre
capacité de de maîtriser la totalité de
notre filière de pollution nucléaire
donc on a un vrai problème de gestion du
des contrats c'est à dire que le
politique en france ne fait pas son job
il a besoin d'apprendre qu'est ce que
c'est que d'être un vrai état stratège à
l'ordre mais ce qu'on ne veut l'éviter
c'est ce dépeçage parce que vous pensez
je ne suis pas moi je suis pas partisan
de la doctrine nationaliste qui pense
qu'on peut arriver à sécuriser à tous
les niveaux la filière économique
française de de la plus grande à la plus
petite
iliad il ya des secteurs de l'économie
qui ont vocation à être internationalisé
et donc il faut comme vous disiez faire
des choix politiques mais dans ses choix
politiques là il faut que le politique
soit présent